recently on Instagram obviously he has
been involved in some entrepreneurship
kind of work etc where there are women
who are addressed inappropriate whatever
you're going through of course that's
your journey that's what it is but doing
it publicly is
unacceptable did you guys know the
definition of emergency is a serious
situation that requires immediate action
imagine your loved ones under a rubble
in earthquake or bombs being dropped in
Gaza or in Yemen or in Afghanistan where
there's an earthquake BR sister we're
working with one um to get immediate
relief to those who are in need please
go to the link and donate whatever you
can inallah and let this be a that use
for your use there for your brothers and
sisters when they needed you the
most brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys insh so I want to
do a video today subh about our brother
D Savage now brother dwood was somebody
who would do skits on uh YouTube um I
wouldn't say reminders but he would do
skits you know about jins and the daily
reminders ET giving Salam whatever is
for that matter and he built a big
audience big big audience over a million
subscribers I'm on YouTube and he was
very very active on Instagram as well
and if I'm not mistaken maybe Tik Tok
and obviously we all get TR and tested
recently on Instagram obviously he has
been involved in some ENT
entrepreneurship kind of work etc where
there are women who are dressed bit
inappropriate he uses music it's a more
going on Etc and people are obviously
upset you go to his comment section and
people are like oh my gosh you want all
that wood back what happened to you
money Fame got to you blah blah blah BL
all this kind of stuff these are firstly
accusations okay we cannot really say
that okay you cannot make this yes of
course we judge was from a parent but to
say that yeah you sold your de you can't
say that you don't know if he's not
praying subh Allah how could you make
this assumption just because he does
certain things that are not permissible
now all of a sudden all his Iman is in
question you can't really say that guy
Subhan Allah yeah I spoke to him and I
reached out to him and I said Aki I'm
here for you I understand if you're
going through something whatever is for
that matter and I'll be honest with I
was very amazed in his reply where he
was like basically saying that the
reason I was thinking why is he leaving
lost comment and he was like you know
what they are rights there is you know
he's like I don't want if he goes even
if you do a video bashing me he goes I
can't blame you and I was like bro I'm
not going to do that I'm not known to do
that I've always reached out to people F
TR Adam s you know Dina Tokyo all these
sisters I've always tried to reach out
to them and reason with them unless they
become arrogant but didn't see that in
him so the point is what brother and
sisters Allah subh says in the Quran we
have found you lost and guided you when
you become religious you start to
there's two issues here number one
looking up to people of religious figure
and making them like holy like proper
holy and they can never make mistakes
expecting too much from them number one
now it's not really your fault because
it's also the fault of the individual
and when you can't live up to that that
eats you alive and when that eats you
alive you have to make a choice can I
live by the standard or I can't and then
you have to pick one or the other
otherwise it eats you up alive so this
is uh one issue number the second issue
is arrogance when we become practicing
and we think and when you think that you
have done this yourself credit belongs
to Allah Allah is the one who guided you
yes Allah subh is the one who guided you
never forget that if you become arrogant
Allah will hit you life will hit you
okay many people get test in different
ways they think yeah I want the manh I'm
this Etc wearing a they it's like a
little movie for them yeah I'm going to
go married I'm going to have couple of
wives and in know horses they have this
dream yeah and then they start looking
down on others and Allah subhana tal
sends them a test that shakes their
world and next thing you know know from
the to the hijab to Min the brother's
beard comes off and all this kind of
stuff I've seen many people in my life
who would Subhan Allah be hostile
towards another brother like w I've seen
this where I don't want to go into
details where they would come and
criticize a certain couple who's on
YouTube because then they were married
couples Subhan Allah and this brother
would come and say yeah this he's like
this he's done that look at them blah
blah and then the next person is
courting clubs a brother will come and
say this guy's not on the man this guy's
not in that and the next brother will
come and say I fell of De I don't pray
anymore I watch pornography and I'm I'm
addicted to masturbation do you see what
I'm saying anytime you become arrogant
Allah will humiliate you and humble you
and again I am not saying this applies
to Brother D the point I'm saying is
this in the comment section many people
are disappointed we want the old that
wood back all this kind of stuff you
know what happened to you the money the
this and that this world is a FNA it can
happen to any of us but one thing you
need to know is that don't become
arrogant number two those people who are
like oh when the old back Etc you may be
tested you may be tested we can all be
tested we can all fall short we are
human beings and these are the things
that keep us in check to give you a
reality check that Allah subhana tala is
the one that's in control and Praises
belong to him this is what is you
acknowledge that all goodness is from
Allah subhana wa tala and your hands
what your hands brought forth sometimes
brother and sisters is what we do to
ourself so I want to say keep Brother D
in your prayers yes okay and of course
what he is doing is absolutely not
permissible he knows that I don't need
to repeat it for someone who knows and
leaving those comments not arrogantly
deleting it yet okay like other
individuals he knows it is Haram and we
ask Allah subhana to rectify his Affairs
and I mean like he's made it clear I
mean it would be nice if you done a
video given a clarification and say look
guys sorry I'm going through something
whatever it is for that matter Etc
please don't follow me I'm like if if I
fell off being like if I may protect me
if I fell off Dean and I was not doing
that way anymore I'm assuming I hope
that I would do a video and say guys I'm
in a bad place I'm not in a right place
I'm telling you guys the videos that
you're going to see for ETC I'm in a bad
place and I'm coping do not watch those
videos do not support I don't support
them I don't condone them this is Haram
whatever I'm just using a mechanism A
coping mechanism to get out of where I
am and whatever I will make that
disclaimer not saying that he has to but
that's all I'm going to say in brother
sisters may Allah subhana tala protect
us all may Allah grant us all a good
ending that's what really matters and
the D is a FNA and a trial may Allah
protect us and the Glamour and all that
kind of stuff W it is it is it catches
up with you bro I know when I was young
and my friend had a BMW convertible bro
I was like what can I do to get this
what can I do to get this because
there's so much pressure peer pressure
we all we're free we're not what can I
do to get this you know and attract
opposite gender you fall for it as a man
our biggest weakness is that Brother D
may Allah bless you may Allah guide you
but the thing is whatever you're going
through of course that's your Journey
that's what it is but doing it publicly
is unacceptable yeah you have a
responsibility yeah you have a big
platform that you've garnered millions
of views and millions of people watch
your content you have a responsibility
if there's something that you're going
through then with all due respect do it
off camera have your thing you know
Rectify your intentions or whatnot do
not do it in front of the people yeah
because this is a very big
responsibility and this is to whoever's
out there when the when you do content
publicly you're held publicly as well
and the thing is that this is it's it's
simply not okay and the people in the
comments that are messaging oh you know
you you did this and you've fallen off
we want the old Da Back good yeah that's
good yeah if you are making comments
like that and you're encouraging the
person to come back we need people like
you and with all due respect uh it is
because of brothers that keep us in
check as well but people there's
something psychological fundament
fundamental attribution error which
sometimes is a mistake but some people
start attributing it to the character
they going deep and heavy that's not
something that's helpful in this
situation what you do is you say look we
want the other we want the old back you
know D you know come back stop doing
this sort of stuff and this that some
people saying like Ali said oh it's his
religion no this is it like he's always
being like this you don't know you don't
know it's very interesting actually he
released a video today in a Rolls-Royce
and he was like um if you pray two ra
before F and he did that just yesterday
yeah and so I I don't know but again
which is also another thing that's very
good that you touched upon that it's
very important do that as well cuz I'm
trying to come from like a different
perspective but it's very important not
only that a lot of your followers feel
like you know what when you was building
your channel it was all Islamic content
but then you get it and I'm not saying
that is the case but they feel like that
they're like you know why is it that you
know be at Tokyo these brothers Etc they
reach a platform and then afterwards
they just do you get it so I'm not
saying you're doing that but that's why
people are upset and it's good they are
trying to call you to
in you want to do that start a new
channel start a new channel that
separate build that up and see if you
know people are going to go there don't
use your Islamic channel that you've and
actually he hasn't on YouTube but
Instagram again he has YouTube he has
but yeah may Allah protect and that was
a very very good point